live local now thank you for joining us  here at noon i'm john langley we'll get  to the weather in just a moment but  first this afternoon umc remains open  despite an early morning murder inside  the hospital metro police say two  patients were attacked in the  psychiatric ward at umc and one of the  victims was stabbed to death detectives  say the suspect is also a patient  someone in his 40's who allegedly left  his room to commit the crimes  he then exited his room  and began to stab another patient who  was on a hospital bed that was located  in the hallway  that victim thankfully was able to get  up and flee  towards the exit doors to that area the  hospital along with a charged nurse  metro says one of the victims of this  attack was actually strapped to their  hospital bed the suspect was taken into  custody including got some help from  corrections officers who happened to be  at umc we'll have a lot more on the  story today at four o'clock a man